in the sprawling Saga that is one piece
filled with epic battles and plot twists
that have kept us on the edge of our
seats all these years we've experienced
countless heart stopping moments these
are the times when it seemed all hope
was lost for our beloved characters only
for them to be miraculously rescued at
the last possible moment it's these nail
biting moments that make one piece one
of the most addictive and captivating
shown in series in the history of the
genre so without further delay let's
dive into the top 20 one piece last
second
saves starting off we have Sanji
arriving in the nick of time to save
dasi from Virgo in Punk
Hazard
lady
[Music]
Pirates and Marines stand at opposite
ends of the spectrum but despite being
each other's throats very rarely do they
cross paths the former are often seen as
Outlaws perpetually pursued by the
latter who are the enforcers of Justice
however when a corrupt Marine sets out
to eliminate his G5 subordinates on the
island of punk Hazard Blackfoot Sanji
arrives just in time to rescue marine
officer stashi from imminent danger now
this particular incident serves as a
prime example of the straw hats chivalry
the Sanji intervenes with a powerful
kick sending the vice admiral Airborne
while sanji's inclination to protect
women due to his romantic nature is
evident what's truly impressive is how
he even with a broken leg takes on the
Peerless Armament Taki use of Virgo
sanji's vant Rescue of Dashi also buys
her fellow Marines enough time to escape
the traitorous Virgos
attack
strike next in line in 19th Place Monkey
D Luffy the charismatic captain of the
straw hat crew steps into protect
Grandpa hoo from the Relentless
brutality inflicted upon him by the
prison guards of
udom it's no secret that Luffy's sense
of justice compels him to take action
whenever he Witnesses the weak and the
defenseless being mistreated this time
too he ends up rescuing hyogoro the
former yakusan boss of wano unconcerned
that the punishment for his actions is
death this event lays the foundation for
a unique mentorship between the two men
under hyogoro guidance Luffy begins to
unlock the full potential of his Hy
abilities marking a significant
milestone in his journey to enhance his
[Music]
power
for our next feature at number 18 we
have the straw hack captains audacious
head-on Rescue of Viola in dress
[Music]
Rosser Don kote do Flamingo not only
manages to survive Luffy's gear for
boundman but starts to wreak havoc again
as his opponent is rendered temporarily
incapable of activating his latest
technique in the midst of this crisis
viona and Rebecca bravely attempt to
confront doy but find themselves
powerless against his string string
fruit abilities just as Rebecca is
forced to harm her aunt Viola against
her will Luffy ever the nation's savior
appears using his harky infused forehead
he shatters Rebecca's blade before it
can reach Viola with Viola out of Palm's
way the stage is now set for the second
round of the Luffy doofy Death Match
ringing in the inevitable end of
doflamingo's cruel
regime for us 17th entury let's Journey
Back to the very beginning of the one
piece narrative when Luffy first sets
out to see for some part of it in a
[Music]
barrel
a in a crucial encounter Luffy rescues
Kobe from the clutches of the slave
driving Captain pyro Alva this act of
heroism swws the seeds of a remarkable
bond between the two young boys one
destined to become the future pirate
king and the other a proud Marine aiming
to become an admiral someday this bold
Rescue of the defenseless Kobe by the
fledgling pirate who doesn't even have a
ship to his name at this point of time
reveals Luffy's character as a
compassionate and righteous hero who's
always willing to risk his life to
protect the vulnerable we've come a long
way from this early scene where Luffy's
seemingly absurd rubberlike Powers were
first introduced but what remains
constant is the Core Essence of Luffy's
character which was first illuminated in
this audacious moment and continues to
Define him to this
[Music]
day next up Frankie saves the
unconscious Zoro in wano a small yet
impactful moment that highlights the all
important Spirit of comradeship between
the straw
[Music]
hats across the treacherous Grand line
the crew sometimes face adverse Aries
who outmatch even the monster Trio of
Luffy Zoro and Sanji Victory often hangs
by a thread as our heroes narrowly
overcome their challenges at such
critical moments when they're either
incapacitated or severely weakened their
loyal crew mates swiftly come to their
aid in this case it's the super Frankie
catching Zoro as he plummets towards
certain death after his victory over
King the Wildfire the straw hats
unwavering trust in each other is a
truly endearing quality throughout their
Adventures this trust has remained
unshaken with each member consistently
proving their reliability when their
comrades are in Dire Straits and Frankie
too as the crew shipwright and trusted
nak plays a pivotal role in providing
essential support and stability this is
evident in his Rescue of Zoro who
himself bravely faced formidable
opponents backto back in the raid on Oni
[Music]
gashima in the 15th position the STW
hats crew's newest edition Knight of the
sea jinbe seamlessly assumes the role of
Helmsman demonstrating his exceptional
skills during the whole cake island arc
as he masterfully navigates the Thousand
Sunny away from the clutches of yonko
big
mom as a fish man jimbe possesses an
unparalleled understanding of the sea
and its currents and his extraordinary
physical strength allows him to handle
the ship's sails with ease as big mom's
colossal wave homie threatens to engulf
the comparatively small vessel sending
fear Rippling through the crew jinbe
remains composed he effortlessly rides
the massive tsunami surfing what's known
as The Green Room which is the inside of
the collapsing wave encountering many
marvelous and terrifying phenomena in
the grand line the straw hat Pirates
finally found the perfect hmen to guide
them on their Journey what this moment
shows us is that jinbe's presence is an
absolute necessity if the Thousand Sunny
is to follow in the footsteps of
Legendary Ships such as the Roger
Pirates oo Jackson and whitebeard's Moby
Dick and secure its own place in
nautical
[Music]
folklore on to number 14 now where we
have Luffy making a dramatic entrance at
the fishmen island Plaza as Hing Jones
is seconds away from executing King
[Music]
neptun now this event unfolds against
the backdrop of the deep-seated enmity
between humans and fishmen making it a
historic moment despite facing ostracism
for some of the fishmen Luffy and his
crew step up to rescue the island
concealed within Prince say Shilah
hoshi's shark Megalo Luffy Springs into
action in gear 2 swiftly delivering a
powerful kick to hodi and sending him
crashing into a wall before anyone can
even react what makes this feat even
more astonishing is that the leader of
the new fishmen Pirates is far stronger
than his usual self after taking an
overdose of energy steroids to
everyone's amazement Luffy not only
saves Neptune but follows up this last
minute rescue with his first conscious
display of conqueror haki incapacitating
half of the 100,000 enemy troops it's a
profound moment as humans traditionally
sworn enemies of the fishmen for
Generations come to their aid and save
them from hodi a mass murderer who
doesn't hesitate to harm his own
kind in the 13th position the Thousand
Sunny finds itself under attack once
again this time from the scary
doflamingo fortunately Sanji swiftly
intervenes as we all know DOI is no
ordinary adversary his devil fruit
grants him the ability to decimate
entire countries and cover great
distances Over the Sea by anchoring
himself to clouds with his strings it's
clear as day that the less powerful
members aboard the Thousand Sunny are
ill equipped to contend with this
ruthless villain however as doofy is on
the brink of annihilating both crew and
ship are trusted swirly eyed cook swoops
into to confront him using his Skywalk
Sanji covers an impressive distance from
Central dress Rossa to the edge of green
bit in a remarkably short time and
incredible speed with only his Diablo
jambe technique Sanji manages to hold
his own against doflamingo who's known
for his formidable Hy skills although
Sanji is ultimately rescued by LW who
uses his powers to teleport doflamingo
away this 11th Hour intervention by
Sanji remains a gratifying Testament to
the rigorous training he underwent at
gaka Kingdom and his growth during the
2-year time
[Music]
skip in one of the most memorable
confrontations between the straw hats
and their opponents the shichibukai
geeko Moria and his colossal pet zombie
ORS nightmare Luffy makes a dramatic
entrance and saves his team from a
ghastly
situation despite the crew's Plucky
efforts to restrain ORS the reanimated
giant gives them a brutal beating ORS is
powered by Luffy's gum gum abilities
with gecko Moria having stolen Luffy
Shadow and fed it to the Monstrous
zombie due to this ORS initially appears
all almost invincible and poses a
formidable threat to the straw hats even
Zoro and Sanji who are no slouches when
it comes to fighting press however
nightmare Luffy intervenes just in time
to save Usopp and Nami from O's deadly
stomping this new incarnation of Luffy
enhanced by the absorption of aund
Shadows into his body delivers countless
blows to the giant as well as gecko
Moria who's inside its stomach one
Unforgettable moment at the beginning of
this spooky battle is when the ghoulish
Luffy effortlessly stops Oz's
devastating rotating punch just the palm
of his
[Music]
hand our pick for the 11th position
comes from oda's Masterpiece the wano
country Arc featuring Zoro in his
zorojuro disguise and Sanji as sangoro
the sober
cook
they create quite a stir as they come to
the rescue of the little Oto in an
emotional scene oto's father the former
Dao yasui meets his end after playing a
crucial role in the Rebellion against
the oppressive forces of kaido and the
usurper Shogun Orochi OKO having just
lost her father in a cruel public
execution is also on the brink of being
killed by Orochi however with the Hat's
present no Injustice can go unchallenged
regardless of the odds Zoro and Sanji
arrive simultaneously to save the young
girl from the shogun's bullets the
significance of his act is Monumental
without hesitation they risk their cover
being blown by openly confronting Orochi
and his henchmen in just a moment the
anguish and despair on the execution
ground gives way to Hope as the two
wings of the future pirate king stand
against
[Music]
Injustice moving on to the top 10 and at
the halfway mark is Monkey D dragon's
sudden and mysterious appearance in log
toown where he prevents Marine Captain
smoker from capturing
[Music]
Luffy as the supreme commander of the
Revolutionary Army and the world's most
wanted criminal dragon's unexpected
presence just when Luffy's nent Journey
as a pirate is on the verge of being
nipped in the bud by smoker is something
to wonder about although Dragon may have
put his family second to the greater
good of the world this early encounter
hints at his undeniable concern for his
son's momentous departure into the grand
line given Luffy's lineage with such
notable figures as his father dragon and
his grandfather the esteemed Marine hero
gar it's only natural for us to believe
that Luffy will be the Catalyst for
significant change in the world and
that's why we eagerly wait the unfolding
of his Destiny with baited
[Music]
breath whenever Sanji goes head-to-head
with an adversary he knows he can't
defeat he almost always makes a powerful
statement this is precisely what he
demonstrates when he faces off against
God enel aboard the ark m him and saves
Uso which is our pick for number
[Music]
nine ensuring Nami and usopp's Escape
Sanji willingly takes nl's lethal
electrical attack head on a second time
having being knocked unconscious once
before but that's not the extent of his
actions here as we already know nl's
abilities possess a wider range making
making it impossible to elude his
assault just by leaping from the ark but
the quick thinking Sanji has a second
layer to his plan as he's already
manipulated the interior of nl's vessel
which ultimately grants his friends The
crucial time they need to flee drawing a
parallel to zoro's selfless sacrifice
for Luffy at Thriller bark sanji's Brave
stand on behalf of his friends in skypia
is equally
[Music]
commendable
up next former Marine Admiral Guan
previously known by his Alias aiji makes
a timely appearance and prevents
doflamingo from killing smoker at Punk
Hazard the conclusion of the punk Hazard
Arc sets it apart from others making it
that much more interesting as the main
action winds up and the straw hats are
well on their way from the island the
Marines come under a prize assault from
doflamingo as doofy mercilessly targets
Smoker's G5 Squad with the intention to
obliterate them entirely we witness
aichi bukai turning against the Marines
contradicting their supposed loyalty to
the world government adding to this
Intrigue then Kuan arrives fresh off his
defeat at the hands of the new Fleet
Admiral sakazuki and his subsequent
retirement from the Marines guzan's last
second Rescue of his former subordinate
and friend smoker reaffirms his
continued commitment to his virtuous
ideals
taking the seventh spot we have Sanji
yes it's him again caught in Black
Maria's web of Deceit and in need of
Nico Robins Helping
[Music]
Hands thanks to his romantic temperament
Sanji Falls right into a trap set by
black Maria one of kaido's toiro despite
the grave danger he's in his unwavering
commitment to his principle of not
harming women nearly costs him his life
responding to his desperate cries for
help Robin promptly comes to his rescue
Landing one of her signature slaps on
the gigantic black Maria some might
mistake San's pleas for assistance in is
calling out Robin's name as an act of
cowardice given that it could jeopardize
his nakama who's being pursued by the
world government for her Pony glyph
deciphering skills however it's actually
the opposite because in truth sanji's
actions reflect his deep trust in
Robin's exception abilities and his
belief that she can easily subdue the
Toby Ropo this seemingly ungentlemanly
behavior on sanji's part is a testament
to Robin's strength which she
unequivocally proves during the ensuing
battle by unveiling her incredible
demonio Flur technique swiftly
dispatching black Maria with a bone
chilling
[Music]
snap
the next entry narrates the touching and
selfless sacrifice of Don kote rosinante
who goes to extraordinary lengths to
save a young Trafalga
[Music]
lore as a member of the donot family and
the younger brother of doflamingo
rosinante operating under the code name
corazone was already treading Ice by
conceding his true identity as a marine
Commander
however when he meets the sick law left
with a mere 3 years to live corazone
goes above and beyond as his benefactor
following 6 months of tiess searching
for a cure corazone finally acquires the
opop devil fruit which holds the
potential to save L's life tragically he
suffers some severe injuries in the
process L unaware of the dire
consequences inadvertently leads Virgo
doy spy within the Marines to corazone
corazon's True Allegiance is exposed
leading to his fatal shooting by doofy
in his dying moments corazone
desperately clings to life maintaining
the protective veil of Silence he'd cast
upon LW using his calm calm fruit powers
and allowing the tearful boy to escape
to safety this act stands as one of the
most heart-wrenching and heroic defeats
in the annals of One Piece history with
corazone repeatedly coming to L's Aid
and even in his farewell offering A
final sacrifice for the young
[Music]
boy
switching things up with a more
light-hearted moment at number five we
have Sanji stepping in to rescue Uso
from the clutches of cp9 agent Jabra
although the situation is far from
amusing for poor
[Music]
Uso
having previously faced humiliation
after refusing to harm another cp9 agent
Khalifa due to his code against hurting
women Sanji once again seizes the
opportunity to redeem himself he takes
on Jabra a formidable takai Kempo user
who Uso is clearly no match for without
sanji's intervention and with Zoro
occupied in his battle against gaku
Usopp would have faced a very Grim fate
indeed however Sanji displaying his
usual calm self grbs the chance to live
up to his status as one of the monster
Trio his Rescue of usant from the big
bad wolf is followed by a pivotal moment
in which he unveils his diabl jamb
technique for the very first time
showcasing his trademark flaming
[Music]
leg why is it that when our cherished
main character is revealed to have been
rescued by a legendary figure our hearts
just swell with pride this brings us to
redhead shank's iconic last minute
rescue act just as young Luffy is about
to be devoured by a sea
king it's remarkable to consider that a
man of the same stature as a legendary
Whitebeard who also happens to be a
former crew mate of the late Goldie
Roger and is now a formidable yonko in
his own right would willingly sacrifice
his arm to protect a young boy that too
from a humble unknown Town shanks
selfless act raises many questions about
his underlying motives yet when viewed
from a simpler perspective it compels us
to admire the veteran pirate for his
principles as he famously states to
Whitebeard later in the story that he
gave his arm to bet on the potential of
the new generation while we may
eventually gain a clearer understanding
of shank's true intentions this moment
remains a touching one as Luffy's
revered Mentor whom he later follows
into the world of piracy saves his life
without a thought for
himself
talking about legendary figures the
third position belongs to the great Sil
Ry as he stops Admiral kizaru from
finishing off Zoro in
[Music]
sabod preceding the time skip the straw
hats find themselves in a precarious
situation as they confront the
formidable might of one of the top three
Marines even Zoro the second strongest
member of the straw hats after Luffy is
easily overwhelmed by the Light human
kizaru as a loia type devil fruit user
kizaru possesses the ability to
manipulate create and control light
making him virtually impossible to evade
for those lacking knowledge of Hy given
that rley takes on the role of Luffy's
Hy instructor after the events of sabod
his timely arrival here cleverly
foreshadows the introduction of haki as
a crucial combat technique that's
indispensable in in the new world
despite his Advanced age rley the
right-hand man of the pirate king
himself adeptly keeps Pace with the
Lightning Fast Admiral and successfully
fends off his assault buying Bartholomew
Kuma enough time to dispatch the straw
hats to safer
[Music]
locations now that brings us to the
runner-up position a poignant moment
involving Port gasty Ace who sures
execution then heroically sacrifices
himself to protect his swarm brother
Luffy by taking a direct hit from
Admiral akainu's magma
fist
[Music]
M while this tragic conclusion might
seem to nullify the great sacrifices
made by the Whitebeard pirates and their
allies as well as Luffy's own desperate
efforts to rescue Ace from execution it
doesn't diminish the significance of the
ultimate sacrifice in one piece history
one that will be forever remembered even
though Ace grew up harboring resentment
towards his Heritage as the son of
Goldie Roger and despising his father
his final moments are filmed with warmth
having found the meaning of a true
family his death remains one of the most
shocking and heartbreaking in the series
it leaves us wondering about the
eventual encounter between l and Ayu
while the pain of losing his brother
will never fade Luffy has undergone
significant changes since the events of
marineford having defeated two yonos and
becoming one himself this raises
anticipation about what the future holds
for
[Music]
him and now we've arrived at that final
pit stop it's time to unveil the winning
moment which is shank's timely Rescue of
Kobe as he locks blades with ay knew
during the dying moments of the summit
war in
marineford
come driven by a sense of Duty and
morality Kobe bravely tries to halter
kyu's ruthless actions which threaten to
prolong the senseless Bloodshed but
rather than deter Aku Kobe's courageous
stand only earns him the Admiral's a
just as Kobe is about to be struck down
by is en rageed Superior Shanks
intercepts akainu's attacks and
announces his arrival to bring an end to
the war the summit War already a
spectacular Showcase of legendary
figures on both sides comes to a
fittingly epic conclusion with this new
arrival once again we're left marveling
at the extent of Shanks his influence
which extends even to the likes of the
former fleet commander sangoku which is
compelled to listen to the redhead
yonko's
words
[Music]
as the one piece Saga consistently
unveils fresh story lines and
captivating characters there's an
abundance of topics to explore so do
subscribe to our channel for additional
one piece and Anime related content if
you enjoyed this video don't forget to
show your support by giving it a thumbs
up if there's something we've overlooked
feel free to share your thoughts in the
comments below until next time ciao